so I remember reading Alan Dibble tones
book the art of travel and I was
extremely struck by the power of this
book to make the suggestion to remind us
rather that wherever we go you know
whenever we head to that elsewhere to
that anywhere but here
we often find that we have to bring
ourselves along for the ride
we look at the brochure can we dream
about who we become when we go to that
place you know we dream about that Beach
we dream about that sunset we dream of
what a fool
we might come in that moment it's really
about hacking our reality you know the
journey is really a desire for self
transcendence a desire for rebirth a
desire for apotheosis it's a very
powerful thing is a very hard thing to
because of hedonic adaptation because
familiarity because we're teens because
traditional modes of thoughts blind us
from the ecstasy of the present moment
they blind us from the hardly bearable
ecstasy of direct energy exploding in
our nerve endings when we dissolve
boundaries when we are here in the now
inspired experiencing revelatory ecstasy
you know making time dilates because of
the poetry of this moment what that we
seek that illumination that catharsis
you know that moment of letting go of
losing ourselves and finding ourselves
you know being inspired
appears by this exquisite I tell is
Asian of the moment and get it so hard
and so what do we do what do we do what
we we create mantras and we create
itineraries and we do drugs and so on
and so forth but it's elusive that space
that liminal space is so hard to tap
into that flow that flow searching for
it man
so I love that word karma not harmonized
right hermeneutics the search for
meaning astronaut boy that is permanent
it's us we are the travelers search of
signification